I'll make you a promise you watch this
movie you will weep I don't even know
the scene you'll do it in just generally
speaking it's swell of positivity bring
the tissues won't you be my neighbor so
won't you be my neighbor is a
documentary it's a peek behind the
curtain of Mister Rogers the man and his
show mr. Rogers neighborhood funny
enough mr. Rogers the man is very much
mr. Rogers that we saw on screen you
always wonder about that where the
character ends and the person begins and
really he was just being himself it's
what I love most about this it's just a
story of a really positive guy who just
wanted to spread positivity throughout
the world and to the youth anything the
documentary it's just a breakdown of
things that I totally missed as a kid
mr. Rogers was like death we're gonna
talk about death because sometimes pets
die what to kid Justin we're gonna talk
about divorce and other heavy-handed
things that most shows to be like nope
let's just give him entertainment Rogers
was like no other people he connected
with kids at a very personal level he
understood that just because kids can't
articulate their thoughts and feelings
as adults do doesn't mean they don't
have thoughts and feelings feeling is
the first thing we do were born we feel
we feel well before we have words and I
love that this shows that Fred Rogers
understood that it's very inspiring
you're inspired maybe you'll be inspired
creatively maybe you'll be inspired to
talk to your family which maybe you
don't talk to them as much as you
probably should point is you'll be
inspired by I didn't know they touched
on relevant issues there was even a
scene he made this profound statement
we're the kids waiting pool him and
someone else dipping their feet in the
pool huge statement it just shows that
you don't need a billion and a half
dollars to make a profound statement you
can do it with your low budget set and a
kid's wading pool subtlety nuance know
what I mean in fact Chris Pratt I think
broke that town vest a little sidetrack
remember Chris Pratt won in a war then
he broke down his ten Chris Pratt rules
one of them was something like if you're
gonna give a dog medicine put the
medicine in a piece of meat the dog
won't even know they're taking medicine
you really think he's talking about a
dog right there he might be but in this
metaphor we people are dogs but the
message in something someone loves
subtlety and they will get it they won't
even know it this movie really is a
celebration of the love of human beings
which is really hard to say these days
social media is just depressing really
for a hundred reasons not only what you
read on social media but how people
interact on
social media Twitter itself is
constructed to either talk trash or
argue which is why if you can't change
it leave it do we need to do to find
happiness I just think civil discourse
has been traded in for the monetary
value of likes and retweets I just do
but this takes it back to the time where
it's lifted up the human interaction is
actually something quite good quite
special this guy really saw the best in
people it's a celebration of the human
experience and that does bring to mind
the fact that mr. Rogers he's a time
capsule mr. Rogers today probably
wouldn't work today only because he'd
probably be depressed because most of
the things he did not like is it's now
everywhere but if there was a mr. Rogers
show today there would undoubtedly be a
mr. Rogers YouTube channel and he would
probably go to the comment section of
those YouTube videos you could just get
depressed dude talk to kids and worked
with puppets those are prime conditions
for some comments section trash talk I
really can't help but see the war of
worlds between the world we have now and
the world that was his in his mind's eye
if for nothing else this movie is a
peaceful protest of the venom entire you
see out there whether it be socially
politically just in general conversation
lines have been drawn it's like you're
either on this side or that side there's
no gray area but everyone's actually in
a gray area they just think they're on
these other sides people have more in
common than they don't have in common if
you're on the other side will now you're
the enemy there are no enemies what we
did enemies even come into it I can't
help but think this movie was made to be
a peaceful protest to that I might be
projecting I don't know might not be in
the end you walk out of this movie
saying mr. Rogers saw the good in people
and it makes you see the good in people
really Fred Rogers figured it out we're
all looking for happiness keeping your
inner child alive doesn't make you
childish it makes you youthful and
that's a good thing no one could ever
look at mr. Rogers and say he was
immature it was well-spoken very
intelligent but he apparently never felt
that growing old meant your childhood
had to die it's such an easy trap to
fall into it's like the older you get
the easier it is to let the joy of your
youth die wither decay it's really the
lesson of Mary Poppins there's nothing
new keeping that youthful Joey alive is
important it's important to carry that
throughout your adult life
he's the endgame he's what we're all
trying to achieve you take me it's like
I want to be happy that means you want
to be more like mr. Rogers you take
anybody well it looks like the stock
market's up 10 points good after all I
just want to be happy yeah you just need
to be more like mr. Rogers cause in the
end won't you be my neighbor it was just
it was sweet and I was welling up with
tears
but I can't actually tell you exactly
when there is a part near the end but I
was just it was a flow and ebb of
emotion half of is probably happiness
the other half is probably sadness of
the fact that we're not gonna get
another mr. Rogers mr. Rogers is mr.
Rogers there's no weather mr. Rogers mr.
Rogers wouldn't thrive in this time but
we have what he gave us so we can carry
it to this time because it's a very
relevant message like his messages then
are very relevant now that's true
immortality right there it's the only
immortality we can ever hope to achieve
live on in your work and have your work
still inspired decades later this
documentary was great in all the right
ways and personally it's just I needed
this doesn't have action it doesn't have
explosions in fact he didn't like
entertainment like that but words always
maintain their power either case won't
you be my neighbor is awesome tacular
so won't you be my neighbor have you
seen it what did you think about it or
what's your favorite uplifting
documentary the one that really hits you
in the fields whatever it is whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]